and and where's the fourth musketeer
where's samantha oh um
she's no longer with us well fans didn't
have to wait long to find out what
happened to samantha jones on the new
sex and the city revival and just like
that if i end up old and alone it's all
your fault oh charlotte sweetie we're
all alone hbo max dropped the highly
anticipated series at midnight on
thursday and within minutes beloved
characters carrie bradshaw miranda hobbs
and charlotte york addressed the
elephant in the room the absence of
their pal sam oh it's been forever do we
hug or bump elbows sign language smoke
signals
where are we these days and and where's
the fourth musketeer where's samantha
yeah the revelation goes down with the
help of a guest star fans will remember
well bitsy von muffling
oh um
she's no longer with us
no no no she didn't die oh no no no i'm
so sorry no i just meant she's not with
us she's in london oh thank god after
the horror show we've been through i
just assume anyone i haven't seen in a
while has passed on or gave up and moved
to palm beach no will fans be given a
satisfying storyline as to her
whereabouts i mean i can't speak for the
audience they have to have that
experience themselves i think what's
wonderful is that we have a writer and
actors who love that character who love
telling stories and being in
situations and environments with
samantha
and we're really lucky we have those
memories and that experience the ladies
have lunch and get into the nitty-gritty
of why their friend really isn't there
with them you know it is kind of like
she's dead
samantha
we never even talk about her
well what is there to say
i told her that because of you know what
the book business is now it just didn't
make sense for me to keep her on as a
publicist she said fine and then fired
me as a friend she didn't fire you
okay she stopped returning my calls you
know samantha
her pride got damaged which was why i
kept leaving her voicemails asking her
to please call me back so we could talk
about this and fix it and just like that
samantha's absence is explained look i
understand that she was upset but i
thought i was more to her than an atm
you are
she was embarrassed so embarrassed she
took a job and moved to london
wait
have you spoken to her
no
neither has charlotte
i mean we texted and called but we never
heard back of course the premiere of and
just like that comes after kim cattrall
who played sam in the original series
made it clear she would not be returning
to the franchise back in 2017 the 65
year old actress told piers morgan that
she and the cast have quote never been
friends i remember so clearly
making that decision
and
last december i got a phone call and it
was concerning that and the answer was
simply
thank you
but no and she told et she would not
participate in what was then thought to
be a third film installment of the
franchise
i feel that the most important thing is
always do we have something left to say
do i want to spend it doing something
that i've explored to the fullest
and let that go and continue with some
do i want to come back and revisit it i
think it's about the story if there's
something more to say but sam's presence
is still felt in the new series even if
kim isn't involved in fact in the second
episode her character makes a touching
gesture to carrie during a difficult
time showing she is still very much a
part of the story line we knew kim
wasn't going to do the series because
she had for her reasons finished playing
samantha so then it was the beginning
point rather than ignore it we decided
to make it part of the story and we did
everything we could to honor samantha
who we love the character and we know
the fans love
no one could be another samantha and at
the new york city premiere on wednesday
night e.t spoke with the show's leading
ladies about samantha's storyline i
personally feel
very pleased with how we've handled it
yeah i think michael patrick
cares deeply about handling it with
respect and i feel that we have and i
feel that it's very real and i relate to
it just from
from being alive you know for as long as
i have been so could kim still make a
return what we needed three single gals
back on the test cynthia told e.t fans
probably shouldn't hold their breath i
think that kim has made it really clear
that she's done and we've heard her and
but i think that i think yeah i think we
deal with it really well i think and
really really creatively